portes closes au cantonnement ces restes
de chalon le commandant de la compagnie
a décidé de ne pas communiquer sur
l'agression de ses hommes silence radio
également du côté de la préfecture ni
communication ni réaction pourtant selon
le syndicat alliance police les
policiers du crs numéro 43 sont sous le
choc
aujourd'hui cette incompréhension c'est
presqu'un un mal-être cette non
reconnaissance que l'on puisse attaquer
des policiers aujourd'hui en france ce
sentiment fait que mes collègues sont
véritablement frustré frustrés déçus
parce qu'on parce qu'on puisse pas ce
qu'on peut les attaquer aujourd'hui
lâchement les gratuitement pas de
réaction du côté des autorités
mais sur les réseaux sociaux les
messages de soutien au policier afflux
citoyens personnalités politiques tous
dénonce la lâcheté de cette agression
le maire de chalon déplore une
banalisation de ce type d' attaques
envers les forces de l'ordre
c'est d'abord la compassion c'est le
premier sentiment qui s'est exprimé on
l'a bien vu sur les réseaux sociaux
deuxième sentiment c'est aussi de la
colère savoir que des crs en
l'occurrence chalonnais mais là ça se
passait ailleurs soit prix est attirée
dans un véritable guet-apens soit
malmené au point que l'un d'eux soit
encore hospitalisés aujourd'hui ces
flottilles mans le sentiment de la
colère qui domine ce soir le crs blessés
toujours hospitalisés au total la
compagnie de chalon compte six blessés
dans ses rangs
dans ce contexte le syndicat alliance
police a demandé la relève du
détachement mission à grenoble pour
éviter toute escalade de la violence